spannt die was für Welt das H
[Musik]
verchl oh oh oh oh
okay ein Autoschlüssel und was ist das
ich im Garten wenn setz setz Loch setz
ich sage wir geh irgendwo auf das
Feld
irg
s ein kreative Idee aber falsch liebe
Mona weß got ich nicht fah
Stund es GT richtig
[Musik]
Oste du das rechts weg Heß in richtig
durau
he zu me m
put da W ihren
Traum lang nervös was erwartet mich
[Musik]
Inus ich se Zirkus oh oh oh oh ich muss
in Zirkus oh mein
gtness guten
Morgen wer erwartet nicht da ich B Mona
ja Willi Willi ja da freut mich und mit
dem Willi GT's direkt
man aha danke schön gr Simona herzlich
willkommenirkus Frau
m s Z Kinder ich B Mona du bist
R
Simone freut mich ich bin Mona und ihr
sind der Zirkus ste genau da sind wir wo
du die
näch und am letzten Tag Überraschung für
dich da WST den du auch der
man
alleine aber das wird
überrasch man super und ich freue mich
sehr für was ist da
zu zuerw ja
okay
no wow also
dreams genau
[Musik]
undor
vorbereitet aber auf allesfasst das ist
Mona m
drin bites schönia zeig mal Platz zum
Schlafen ja
hi
schnell ja
also ja also natürlich das groß
gen du
da
Platz
schön ne ich muss aber ehrlich Z ich bin
überhaupt ke Camperin ich hab noch nie
im Wohnwagen
geschlafen
definitivang direk wohnwag ist sch ewig
als zum Zirkus Abau
heü im Zirkus Stei versied
nationenle aus Tschechien der K und Frau
wchen ist Frankreich und er wo der
Abfall
wegumb
zirkussch und in der mane werdet pon
trainiert vom faren Bar der FIS ist für
Tier zuständig undt aus
[Musik]
Marokko und er der Martin Stei all das
als
Zirkusdirektor 201 der Familie Zirkus V
Elteren über und führ mit Frau
M
[Gelächter]
das wohnzimmerch wohnwage
oder
super 24
Stund sch und
sch und
Bezi das
ein ja also das ist sicher lernt oder im
Zirkus ja zum einfach gewisse Sache sag
okay ist wichtig D diskutieren
zusau genau fertig und
wier
Schlafzimmer
fü dich wieder
sweethart zu mir sweethart g
nein redet ihr
Englisch speak English ja ja
dasine du h immer W selber auch im
Zirkus sie den später nein ne B ne also
nein nein also ich hab immer gesagt ich
werde immer ich gesagt und ich immer mir
irgendwo g sind m hat man immer auf dem
burof gefunden aber also dann hat
einfach ge du bist in der zirkusfilie
groß Word muss über ne nein nein das hat
ne überhaupt nicht mir hat auch gesagt
dass
ich lehergang will machen Automechaniker
ja und dch irgendwie h das auch nicht ja
das nicht so kann ich mich den ander
entschlossen aber es wäre natürlich
auchum Vorteil g für mich wenn ich leer
gemacht hätte ja oder den nach hät wenn
ich jetzt nicht übern hätte W es
geschafft dann hätte ich natürlich eine
bessere Option gehab mit leherabschluss
od mir auch gesagt meine Frau nicht mehr
dass derolf und Simone das die leer
machen ja und nachher wenn es nicht W
der Zirkus übern wo
mir kann ja passieren weiß man nicht den
zig der Hand mit meen Abschluss und zgis
zu zu Job finden
od Mia kennt zirkusleber aus dem FF sie
stammt aus ein amerikanische
Zirkusfamilie aber da ist jetzt mal im
Vorteil oder wenn man nicht allzu groß
gewachsen
ist sind Vater und wir sind
allewt und alles
gell das ist halt so
gell bet ja so kurz V spieen
sehr
fein bin ich J lang
zum zum
Zirkus mit
ihremkel und dann
bin ich w Amerika fer den wieder gesehen
nicht aber nicht ganz zufällig also
eigentlich du sie gesehen gefunden ja
also ja ja nach in Amerika den ja D bin
ich den wieder und dannch andere
flugbillett du h das flugbill
geschickt ja komm mir komm
ja er hat mich um hilf B und ich bin und
unterstützt
aber bli bist nicht nur zum
Helfen offensichtlich
nicht ist es immer es Geschenk wei D man
so Trin geboren wird oder kann
auch Last sie für mich ist es kein Last
oder dass ich da drin geboren bin ist B
schön oder dafür hat man halt andere
Sachen nicht kein sommerferi h weniger
Ferien zirkusdektor werden
Direktorin aber aber du ah
gut gerade hinterm wohenwag sind
gei das mal der
Bamby der Rino super und also mit den
macht ihr
denn vorfüg in der mane ja das ist das
istftritt du machst gei num okay also
ich ftr mit der gei ja okay das min
aufgab
jawoh okay also UI also
ja ich freue mich sehr aber ich glaube
es wird schwierig für
mich besser gei als Pony
die Pony sind der Mia ih Nummer normal
machen luftnum aber jetzt ich bin ein
bisschen alt für der luftnum AH Luft
also was
trapz ja das W immer TR und wie bist du
zu
ponis
ich ich m springen ich nicht was ich ma
aber irgendwie hert das Fin ich spannend
we man sich vorstellt jeder den das
machen wo ein am besteft aber Zirkus ist
nicht
so nein sch brucht wenn das vor ist dann
bist vorne wenn das hinten ist B
hin oder WN krank ist dann springt
einfach
h wie heißt der du bist
Chef der Tony wnwagen
Grill Gag du s a schon mega lang da wie
viel J sch als Kind ich habe ke
Elter Kinderheim ist ander V einer
plegfamilie zu andere aber bin ich immer
ab und immer bin ich Zirkus gangen bis
BB da was den gesucht als B im Zirkus
Nestwärme
geborheit ich hab gefunden und zw
schönste hab ich da gefunden
ist eigent me
einzige Familie einzige Ding wo wirklich
für mich
da drag bin ich Teil von der
[Musik]
Familie
montiert B hallo
[Musik]
mit ja schön Dich kennenzulernen Arbeit
du auch in
der was ist
deinob okay also du bist die
Schlangenfrau okay wow aber ist das
normal dass ihr zwei Jobs habt immer
immer in Zirkus muss man alles können
also in der Frau in den Zirkus sie macht
einfach alles okay super also Popcorn
ist ready du auch ich auch
[Musik]
hoffentlich super
a
danke danke
vi danke schön aber wirklich viel lauft
nicht es
nur das git zum andere Mitarbeiter
kennenlernen hallo ich bin
Mona fre
mich
ein andere Job ja wir sind artiste mir
schli und ma
Akrobatik dann freue ich michftritt aber
zeig mal vorher wie mit zuckerw
macht einfach
drei dir
einfach das kannst du
auch Schluss so
aus also soll ich jetzt probieren oh ne
oh ne
oh
richtig gar nicht so schlecht a
furbar das F über Profis bald Gott
vorstellig
[Musik]
los
pensioniert wir
leit ganz klar und ganz viel Spaß in
ihrem Schweizer traditionszirkus Stei
traditionszirkus es ist wirklich Zirkus
wie früh inklusiv num
[Musik]
Girl Jasmina wo vorher gerade no poorn
und Glasse verkauft ist jetzt voll ihrem
Element
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und auch der Dani und der ASI vom
zuckerwatstand sind am
vi s mal pro Woche ST der mane während
der Saison spielt der familiezirkus rund
3 vorstell
[Applaus]
verschiedenenort
und
[Musik]
konzent machbarus GE
W
geh geh schön bra bra
bra
so ma
FE
Schlussapplaus und dann ist sch verbi vi
Ali zü sich zurück in
[Applaus]
Wohnwagen
[Musik]
das ist also der zirkusalltag gar nicht
glamurös aberf Erle ich Mens da als echt
und
herzlich Papa Z für
[Musik]
bet
ich
[Musik]
Sch
min erste Nacht im Wohnwagen ist
überstandeneschlafen
ich
aber Kaffee
[Musik]
versprochen
ja danke
viel
A mitang
20 du
Sixpack noch jetzt ist
[Gelächter]
epack
also debü für Miria wo die a generation
V ihrer Zirkusfamilie repräsentiert da
zu D Kind auch automatisch
mitchaff ganz
frü ja aber dass das für dich gar nicht
richtig weg was ist denn wenn du
typicht
für dich ja für dich für mich
stimmt vi sie zum Reden BB
n ich begleite der Martin
auf nächste
platzusmess als Zirkusdirektor muss er
immer paar schrittus denk und mit all
alles mögliche
besprechen
a sprach V polnisch bis rumänisch ist
sicher ke
Nachteil das der
Platz
Platz zirkusfilie ste über 500 J Land
sie sind eine V der ältest
zirkusdynastieon der
Welt
es W immer schwieriger PLZ find undlage
geminden und Behörde wer immer strenger
let J Schwizer Zirkus zuemacht es sich
schlicht Verantwort
du
riesig
natürlich S oder GT schlaflose Nacht
wenn du so
kopfüber was wenn wie so natürlich gibt
das das gibt auch
ja ich
nicht sich Gedanken oder ja das sind
halt auch ja es ist wirklich sch halt ja
es ist schwierig schon oder
natürlich ich mein du bist jetzt was 500
Jahre Dynastie geschich oder
traditionszirkus
ja die Generation sie mus sagen mir geh
oder ich das immer so wenn ich sehe dass
es nicht dass es nicht meh riert ja dass
ich nur no duf und alles ma ma lieber zu
als ich g Konkurs machen ja zur
Sicherheit h sich
zweitutachtszirkus lauft sie z Jahr mit
derfolg der wnachtszirkus das neu das
ist auch B neues ja ja einfach dass man
mehr so auf Events setzt selber statt
einfach
das ist ja das ist der
wnachzirkus ist gut Dafen wirklich sind
sehr glücklich sind sehr sehr froh
drüber aber ich g nicht das Geld W ich
im Winter verdient hab für für z stecken
und dass ich nachherich sommerzirkus ma
ja also
imid dasöglich das ist
gutöglich
Wanderzirkus Zunft Z sind Martin teren
auf 28 Jahr
lang
zirkusürt
immer noch mir fät alles einfach alles
der Zirkus fällt
mir vom Stress über
ja ja ganzes Leben und den plötzlich h
kein gamping ist schwer
schwer sind
vorstell das and aber Bedürfnis Zirkus
immeration
anders aber im Prinzip ist immer no gich
kanst du nicht
neufen das lauft und wenn man das auf
der auf dem Ding bliebt wo man der
Zirkus immer gemacht wird immer
funktionieren der klassische Zirkus also
wirklich der klassis Zirkus so W jetzt
der Martin noch macht der hat immer noch
Chance wo der GL geht was braachtischoh
mit der roten ne der King und solange
Dasing
ja
das V
Zirkus ich bin
skeptischer Cirkus Z
momentan Schwiz
konkurrenzhbot
riesig aber fertig schwarz jetzt
Prob was muss ich machen
genau
okay und sie weiß was sie muss machen
eigent
aber also B ja gut
gut
bravo bravo super du bist die beste sie
Hand und sie weiin gut am
Platz fürich ich glau sie weiß ja elich
was
S ge weiß es weiß es du ja ich auch
ich aha brauche ich Hilfe
Mona stay little bit
strong
[Gelächter]
z okay
also großen
Auftritt
ja für
dich also ich
maitte also
ich ja du ja aber du bist im Zirkus und
ich
hey jetzt noch
VR ich hil F
pon der Schwiz schon für viel
verschiedene Zirkus
gchaff hilfst auch aufbauen oder w ich
bin fertig im stah und dann ich sehe
Leute arbeiten dort ich habe ich habe
nicht gerne zum Sitzen und schauen
andere Leute Arbeit die gehen her ist
ist eine Familie als ich noch ein Kind
war war der Zirkus weißt du große
Attraktion und all ja sag mir wie war es
früher wie ist es heute das ist ganz
anderes ja früh ist es wann es kommt
Zirkus im Platz dann siehst du viele
Leute viele Kinder helfen alle da und
jetzt Moment nein macht dich das traurig
macht ser traurig ja ja ja ja ser
traurig nicht nur wegen Direktor wegen
uns auch wegen W ich arbeiten im Zirkus
in Manager und ich sehe viele Leute ich
bin so ich bin noch mehr Kraft aber WN
ich sehen wenig Leute macht mich sie
müde ja WE zu viel Arbeit wegen
was auch wenn es streng ist alle ziehen
am gich Strick anders got nicht so musst
m am
grillstandelfen der Ton FT er der
[Musik]
chall und ich stand
Buff WN nicht vol
[Musik]
wir
und herzlich willkommen im Zirkus
Stei min zweite Nacht im Wohnwagen ist
besser undich bin ich Gil V
entspannt ja bist
bereit
so okay me ja du bist
klein also auf der Liste V was wirst du
nie im Leben willenle ich das Recht wie
ob aber da das da ich gelernt ja im
Zirkus ist es so da frag dich eigentlich
nie war hast du Lust sondern ja es heißt
einfach also gut da ist numere da
Hel und dann Leib ihr m eigentlich EU
eigene Ego immer un das ganze Stellen
genau
Pass ein in man ja alles ist
weg ja also Spiel Rolle genau ja okay
also ich g N vor zwei Tag hätte ich mich
geigert zum und jetzt ich sag ja da ist
so wie es da funktioniert
also Show first Ego
second ich aufplatzt wenn ich in der
mane bin ja
den oh mein
Gott das nehme ich mit die eige
Befindlichkeit spielt im Zirkus nie
Hauptrolle das istim Ton so morgen
morgen alles klar ja dir so wie ja
wie und B immer da schaffen
wieso das ist
Zirkus behandl was
denkin ich
wirklich we nicht
noch ja aber mein Wunsch ist eigentlich
dass ich da beim Zirkus kann
sterben und ich bin auch sicher dass
wenn et ist bei mir
dass der Vater und Mutter von Martin
auch für mich da sind sie sag h no du
gehörst zu ich hab zwar nicht nam das
ist auch gich aber ich fühle mich wie
eigen ja also wie ein Sohn wir behandelt
ja ja da viel das bedeutet mir sehr viel
ja s sehr Herz
[Musik]
gewachsen was für das Paradox das Leben
im Zirkus so glitzernd und magisch und
gleichzeitig
[Musik]
hammerht aber auch Gemeinschaft wo
Geborgenheit GT und der
Familie
[Musik]
macht stolz was was I aufbaut ich meine
sind die Generation aber man muss den
machen
ja wir sind sehr stolz auf
NAT Zukunft LT wie lang gbt ein
Wanderzirkus wirklich WE zu
me Wunsch W natürlich die Z das W wifüen
sicher wo wir da ja jetzt machen oder
und die W Zirkus oder we das ist auchis
für sie für Zukunft oder das wäre ein
Wunsch ja also dass es eigentlich
genauso wier geht da wä ein Wunsch ja
ja dass der Zirkus lauft dass immer wird
laufen das ist mit Traum das ist meine
li ich nirgendwo glücklicher se
ja ein Traum ist W worden nämlich der
mit
ih
Traum ja bittey und jetzt hoffe ich
ruinierechmittag
programmin wiederhol wieder
von jetzt g
Ernst ich im
[Musik]
ich TR und ich versu mit
F jetzt nur no
[Musik]
ge
okay los mega nervös mega
schlimm
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja h
kom h
kom
voilلا
гра så aber B
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja es ist so schnell verbegangen aber
ich bin so froh sie h m
ver gar nicht
gesehen
nervö ganz ehr
zirkuspremiere he Simone du bist super
du hast mir so geholf danke viel
mal mer viel mal bitte bitte bitte danke
viel bitte schön
vermich auch vermissen aber ehrlich ich
sit doch jetztber wieder im
Publikum und so Gang mit viel Respekt
für das wo die Familie ttäglich
[Musik]
leistet